John's with us in Atlanta Georgia hi
John welcome to the Dave Ramsey show I'm
very very did better than I deserve
what's up well I want to know exactly
where to get started I've kind of got
ourselves in a little budgeting mess so
don't know where to start what kind of
mess about $46,000
the one good thing is the house has paid
off okay but you have 46,000 dollars in
debt yes sir okay on what a car student
loans credit cards loans and so it's
starting to pinch on you then yes sir
what's the household income the
household income is about thirty-eight
okay and what do you owe in the cars
nine thousand okay all right well what
the there's two main things that I would
want you to do um one is to start with
the written budget where you are going
to sit down before the month begins look
at your income and give every one of
those dollars of your income for this
month a mission if every dollar a name
an assignment and you started you know
you start with food and shelter and
clothing and transportation and
utilities you take care of household
first right the basic needs of the house
and then from there you start looking
going okay what can I do next
obviously you need to pay the single
payments on all this debt you can do all
of that barely but you can do it and
then I want you to start setting some
goals with any money you can squeeze out
of the budget and what can we sell what
can we have a garage sale can we work
extra hours what can we do to create
some money to begin to whittle down this
forty six thousand dollars in debt and
so if you were to able to whittle down
twenty three thousand a year you could
do it in two years you're probably going
to take you three years okay unless you
have something big that you sell in this
mess here now once you looking big once
you've gotten the written plan going
and you're got your monthly expenses
under control and the monthly dollars
flowing to the debt as fast as possible
then we work what we call the baby steps
and baby step one is your first goal is
I want you to save $1,000 do you have
any money saved okay so your first goal
is $1,000 set aside as a starter
beginner emergency fund okay so you got
a thousand bucks the bank then once
you've done that you can do that
probably in about a month baby step two
then is I want you to list all of these
debts smallest to largest and pay off
the smallest one as fast as you can
while paying minimum payments on the
other just hammer that smallest debt as
hard and as fast as you can and then
work your way right down that list and
that that's what we're going to teach
you to get out of debt have the written
plan but the thousand dollars in the
bank and then work your debt self
smallest to largest I'll send you a copy
the book the Total Money Makeover which
will help you do all of this it's going
to show you exactly what to do how to do
it and hold on the line I'll have Kelly
pick up and I'll be happy to give you a
copy as my gift hey you guys Rachel
Cruise here hope you are enjoying the
Dave Ramsey show and did you know that I
have my very own YouTube channel yes
that's right kind of better than
I'm kidding I'm kidding so subscribe and
there's lots of videos about life and
money so while you're at it if you want
to check out a video then you can check
out how to do a monthly budget it's one
of the best videos out there
you